a special gift yeah apparently this is a
birthday gift for me and I was like what
could it be and then I saw the can
opener I was like oh
[__]
just I'm waiting for it to hit can't
open I'll give you a hint I'll give you
a hint thank you oie
botulism oh
no oh that's why that's why it's wrapped
in
newspaper oh no dude I'm not even here
right now are you jetlagged or something
yeah yeah no I'm I mean everyone says
that's Sommer strong will cure your jet
leg we'll cure your jet lag it's the
best remedy for it everyone's beening
bro a bro I'm scared look at
this oh man I can sense the
botulism can you smell it already I
thought I did I might have imagined
that where did you get this from yo this
is like a grenade going off hold up some
like Swedish website yo you have buckets
back here so we can puke yeah there puke
buckets
too courtesy of Dome
Depot it's different from Home Depot man
I just ordered my favorite burrito and
then you're going to you're going to pav
law of poison what is
this what is this now oh that's like a
Cai tab you can take it after you no
it's raspberry and orange lure
chocolates oh yeah that'll [__] cure
whatever's little apertif is that what
that is here it is
folks I mean The Branding is [__] ace
yeah no that's a it is sick design I
should probably have
gloves oh no we talk about man you've
had some sneaky fish on your fingers
before
nice all right here we go not Lauren put
her camera down on that one she's like
absolutely not by the way if you
actually don't know what this is just go
to Tik Tok search sir strings fish and
you can see people like videos of people
struggling to like breathe as soon as
this can is open yeah it's crazy they
actually get these from the bottom of
the Titanic all right the seal has been
cracked that [__] H
dude dude smell that man no dude that
smells like eggs oh my God that's
straight up S
[Applause]
wer oh my you don't smell it uh no I
think get stuck in my nose yeah it is
dude that smells like rotten
EG no shot I'm going over there
no I'm not this is not an exag geration
that is the worst thing I've ever
smelled I actually can't get close to it
put it in here I can't get close to
it
bro dude that smells like a handy Gump
that's like if you
put I'm to get it real
quick wait what wait wait wait mix with
the [__]
oh my God that makes it worse dude dude
D there's some juice right there that's
that scense not going away bro no no no
no no that is unironically I caught a
whiff of that I'm notg I know right it's
horrible oh that that does make it worse
cuz now now it actually smells like Andy
Gump no this that yeah the fabreze mix
with it is
horrendous oh bro smells like ba like
public bathroom in here
do we have any other air freshener oh
ew oh that just ruined my
Saturday can I use this
yeah do whatever blow this place
up yeah dude smell that no I don't need
to I got a whiff I got a
whiff I can't believe people actually
eat that like that's not just for
smelling I can't focus it's still
here yeah it's going to be it's going to
be around I think it's
still I think it's gone I think it's
gone all right I think it's
time
oh wait wait let me get another sip of
my coffee before it's
ruined can I go in the
doorway that's actually probably a worst
position the C hands are stamped bast
for that means it's recommended to
consume it before that date no they're
not no it's
not it's probably rubbed off did you buy
this from like an official
reseller yeah I'm finding it from their
website no I'm looking dude no shot you
will not get sick from
that so do but like in order to like do
that I have to open it up it's going to
[__] smell
oh brother no way you make it through no
way you make it
[Music]
through dude I just spill [__] liquid
on the carpet awesome that's good I mean
that wasn't my
fault yeah get through this
Lauren can't do it she can't even
[Music]
take
it already is all
over it's my birthday present I have to
do
it dude if I someone's got to help
me bro
that
here you got to no come on
dude it don't be careful that it doesn't
spray the juice up dude that smells so
bad what you want the juice no I just
want to see the
fish oh wait get a shot of
that oh my
God
eat it let's get out of
here I just lick it no eat it eat
[Applause]
it so salty dude that tastes like
[__] U it tastes like umy
dude eat it it's like
sushi
okay I'm
done that it's really
salty oh my
God I'll tell you what it smells a lot
worse than it
tastes I swear to God I could actually
probably eat that on some
toast